hi i'm sue bird and my favorite movie is
goodwill hunting
in my glove in my little league glove is
that too gross
[Music]
i think i love goodwill hunting for like
the plot itself like just the story
i think is really good but it's also got
some one-liners man that just
i mean how do you like them
i'm allison felix and my favorite movie
is coming to america
i love the wedding scene and when
um she's like hopping on one foot and
doing the whole like barking bit and all
that stuff
i'm chloe and my favorite movie is there
will be blood
i guess my favorite thing about there
will be blood is actually the stillness
of the shots and then also the job
daniel day lewis does is captivating my
favorite movie of all time
is kill bill i watch kill bill probably
every night
seriously what i love about kill bill is
how
everybody was down on the bride and
she had to overcome everything and get
back what was rightfully hers
hi i'm chuck aoki and my favorite movie
is airplane you're cream abdul jabar no
i'm not
roger murdock i'm an airline pilot
i think you're the greatest but my dad
says you don't work hard enough on
defense
listen kid you tried dragging walk my
beer up and down the court for 48
minutes
i bust my ass every night i first saw
airplane uh my dad rented it from the
old the old uh
mr movies we had 5.5 movies for five
bucks and i watched it and it was just i
was like 12. it was
so funny to me i've never seen a movie
so funny and i still haven't seen a
movie that funny actually you ever
hang around the gymnasium we better get
back now
i'm christian taylor and my favorite
movie is black hawk down
i love black hawk down because i just
love soldiers the passion for defending
something they believe in
[Music]
hi i'm julie ertz and my favorite movie
is remember the titans
i just love this story like i love the
characters
i just love sports and what sports does
and that kind of talks all about it
i love when they like come out and they
like you know dance when they come out
[Music]
my name is tamira mensa stock and my
favorite movie is the little mermaid
dialing it's better downward sweater
take it from me
i love it my favorite scene
it's actually what uh sebastian says he
said
teenagers they think they know
everything
you give them an inch they swim all over
you i'm nigel houston and my favorite
movie is blood diamond
i feel like it's very uh it's real you
know very realistic i mean that stuff
actually happened
um yeah to anyone who uh who hasn't seen
it definitely watch it
i'm trevor crabb and my favorite movie
is happy gilmore
just because of the way he was he was
like a rebel coming into something new
there's just just so many great
one-liners from that movie
oh why didn't you just go home that's
your home
are you too good for your home answer me
i'm megan rapino my favorite movie
shawshank redemption why should i
believe a smart banker like you
so i can end up in here with you it's
perfectly legal go ask the rs they'll
say the same thing
it's just so good the acting is
phenomenal it's just like about what's
right and what's fair and like never
giving in my favorite movie which is the
greatest of all time which has been her
favorite scene in ben hur is actually
when uh
you know he's been enslaved and he's
being taken to the galleys and
he encounters jesus for the first time
[Music]
favorite movie oh yeah i'll go training
day cheering today is my favorite movie
i need that bag jake give me the bag
jake and then i'm gonna get that money
and you ain't gonna do a damn thing
cause you ain't gonna shoot no cop in
the back are you i used to live in
pittsburgh and i lived there i didn't
have cable for a while
so i had um a little dvd player and i
watched
training date all the time i'm katie
ledecky and my favorite movie is notting
hill
so so i saw you put that book down your
trousers
pork book the one down your trousers
i think the first time i watched notting
hill
was probably with my family at home
probably
watched it together on dvd or something
my name is scout bassett and my favorite
movie
is to kill a mockingbird and i might be
a little biased
don't you remember me miss cunningham
i'm january's finch so i first saw to
kill a mockingbird when i was
in middle school and seeing the
character
scout gave me so much pride because you
know when you're young people kind of
make fun of
like having an unusual name but to see
to kill a mockingbird and who that girl
represented and what she was about gave
me a lot of pride
[Music]